After entering puberty, pubic hair begins to grow in our external genitalia. But with
With hair removal and beauty becoming a common personal habit,
Is it really good to trim or wax to remove the hair below? Or is it overgrown?
After the last ice age, humans lost most of their body hair about 70,000 to a million years ago.
Although most of the hair is gone,
Rich hair in the armpits and underarms
Make humans the only mammal in the world with long, thick pubic hair.
Researchers believe that pubic hair is a visual signal after humans have passed puberty
Used to attract potential mating objects
Moreover, the thick pubic hair can prevent the damage caused by friction during sexual intercourse. Another theory involves sweat.
Humans have two types of sweat glands, one type that mainly secretes water and salt, and has no taste.
The other gland is mainly distributed in the underarm and pubic area.
Through the hair follicles, the secretions are rich
Protein, lipids, and pheromones. And when these molecules are broken down in the bacterial skin, body odor is produced.
During the evolution, humans retained these hairs and made pheromones
Attract potential sexual partners. This argument is supported by the fact that women
In order to give birth and conceive during ovulation, different pheromone messages will be released.
Make yourself more sexually attractive. But a study in the United States
It was found that among the more than 1,000 students, in the past month, 96% and 87% of women had some or all of them.
Remove pubic hair. However, no matter what form is used to remove hair, when the pubic hair grows again
Regenerated hair can irritate the skin. Actually,
75% of people with pubic hair experience have had genital itching, 40%
Experienced some type of rash.
Shaving and waxing can cause the hair to grow out smoothly, but grow inward.
Causes red and inflamed rashes. Interestingly, these conditions
In fact, shaving and wax removal have reduced haze
However, these practices can also cause minor injuries on the skin.
This can lead to infections and even infections.
In theory, it is believed that pubic hair removal may also increase
Gonorrhea, infection with chlamydia and papillomavirus. Even if you don't consider infection
According to reports of the most common genital injuries in the US emergency room,
It happens in the process of removing pubic hair. At the end of the day, regardless of
What new hair removal tools are currently available,
Let the pubic hair develop naturally and there is absolutely no harm to human beings. Before we finish, we want to send an oversized one.
Thank you for
There are great ideas and content here.
Thanks for watching.